So, I'd like to end with a summary of what I've looked at today,...
...and some recommendations.
The figures show that sales are strongly seasonal,...
...and that customers depend on good information on the showroom floor.
So, I'd like to recommend we concentrate on discounting in the off-seasons,...
...and spend more time on briefing our sales representatives.
That's all I have for now.
Are there any questions?
You mentioned that the sales figures may also reflect economic trends.
Can you expand on that?
Well, we are always going to depend on the economy.
As I understand it, we can look forward to an improvement this year.
Does that answer your question?
Are you saying we're in for a period of growth?
Well, I'm afraid that's a bit outside my area of expertise,...
...but that's what the papers are suggesting.
If you believe it.
You suggested that we might be spending too much on advertising.
Can you clarify that?
It's hard to quantify without better data.
Sorry.
Could you repeat that?
We don't have the figures to really know how effective our advertising is.
In my experience, you can't do without advertising.
Time for one last question.
I have one.
Yes, John?
Is it time for coffee?
Okay, we'll wrap up now.
Thank you for your input, everyone!
Thank you.